die tore sind zu rehan blatt nur der
sehnsüchtige blick auf den alten
pausenhof es ist der blick zurück auf
eine kindheit die nicht mehr sein darf
das war meine schule hier war ich bis
zur fünften klasse ein klassenzimmer war
da hinten und vorne haben wir immer
cricket gespielt das ist alles vorbei
meine freunde sehe ich nicht mehr die
schule ist seitdem lockt und zu seit 18
monaten und ich arbeite als
gemüseverkäufer
statt unterricht also arbeit statt
schulhof großmarkt
frühmorgens schon rein ins getümmel und
gewusel da sind die waren frisch
rehan ist erst 14 aber schon mittendrin
er kaufte ein um weiterzuverkaufen geld
zu verdienen erarbeitet damit seine
familie überleben kann
da ist keine zeit mehr für kindheit
keine zeit mehr für schule
immerhin hilft es mir jetzt dass sich in
der schule mathe gelernt habe ich muss
ja wissen wie viel geld kann ich
ausgeben wie viel bekomme ich zurück die
ganze rechnung ich darf nicht zu viel
sein alles muss stimmen da muss ich
genau rechnen
mit 14 in der welt der großen feilschen
um kartoffeln blumenkohl gurken
2700 rupien gut 30 euro investiert die
herren wenn es gut läuft und er alles
verkauft macht er drei euro tagesgewinn
jeder cent zählt
einmal habe ich kürbis gekauft der schon
total verrottet war der händler hat die
nicht zurückgenommen an diesem tag haben
wir 1000 rupien 11 euro verloren
eine teuer bezahlte lehre was für eine
verantwortung
wo ist rihannas vater weg heißt es da
nur er ließ die familie sitzen in der
krise der wirtschaftlichen not im langen
lockdown einfach weg am stand der mutter
ist rehan deshalb unverzichtbar
der älteste der vier söhne muss mit
arbeiten mit verdienen und sich von
allen anderen plänen verabschieden
würde ich weiter zur schule gehen wäre
ich gern beamter geworden ein guter job
aber jetzt verkaufe ich gemüse
von der hand in den mund wie für so
viele die in armut geboren sind scheint
es auch für rehan keinen ausweg zu geben
im gegenteil die pandemie hat alles noch
auswegloser gemacht arme familien können
sich bildung kaum leisten
als mutter möchtest du dein kind zur
schule schicken wenn du das nicht kannst
fühlst du dich schlecht ist beschämt
mich
dann hat das leben vor sich und sollte
es nicht damit verbringen gemüse zu
verkaufen aber selbst wenn die schule
wieder eröffnet wir haben kein geld für
bücher hefte stifte wir brauchen alles
vermute fürs essen
schuften stadtschule kinderarbeit in
indien viele gesichter es gibt sie
überall die fabriken auf feldern auf der
straße offizielle zahlen sprechen von
zehn millionen hilfsorganisationen von
40 50 millionen kinderarbeiter
gesetze verbieten dass und die
verfassung garantiert ein recht auf
bildung die realität sah schon immer
anders aus und jetzt erst recht corona
holt kinder aus der schule und treibt
sie in die arbeit der
friedensnobelpreisträger keiner stadt
lahti kämpft dagegen an doch seine
sorgen wachsen
da die pandemie die ganze welt jeden
betrifft dachten wir erst diese krise
wird die menschen gleicher machen ehe
mal sehr sehr cool
aber das gegenteil ist wahr die pandemie
hat ungleichheiten und ungerechtigkeiten
offengelegt und verstärkt
unglücklicherweise bekommen dass vor
allem kinder aus unteren schichten
besonders hart zu spüren
schule ist der schlüssel könnte der
schlüssel seien aber wegen der pandemie
sind viele noch immer dicht seit
eineinhalb jahren das ist echter
bildungsnotstand
durch die slums von delhi durch ein meer
der hoffnungslosigkeit bahnt sich jetzt
der hope bus seinen weg
wenn die kinder nicht zur schule kommen
können kommt die schule eben zu den
kindern
so gibt es endlich wieder unterricht
aber es ist mühsam viele haben vergessen
was sie mal gelernt hatten vor corona
vor dem schul lockdown die lehrerinnen
wie isabella werden von spendern
finanziert und vom eigenen idealismus
angetrieben
[Musik]
corona hat die kinder aus der bahn
geworfen so lange ohne unterricht heißt
wir müssen viel aufholen in besser
gestellten familien können sie online
unterricht machen aber arme haben keinen
computer kein mobiltelefon und viele
eltern können kaum helfen weil sie
selbst nicht lesen und schreiben können
indien hat über lange zeit große
fortschritte in der bildung seiner
kinder gemacht mühsam errungene erfolge
die nun von der pandemie durchkreuzt
werden
schule ist für viele eltern jetzt
nebensache für die familien ist es
wichtiger jeden tag zu überleben wir
müssen ihnen klar machen wie wichtig
bildung für die kinder ist aber für die
eltern ist das nicht leicht zu verstehen
wenn sie in solcher armut leben
imhof bus gibt es mittags eine warme
mahlzeit schule macht satt heißt ein
hungriges kind weniger ein argument das
bei vielen eltern zieht liebe geht durch
den magen bildung manchmal auch